bonjour madame bonjour
moi je voudrais voyager voyager vous
voulez voyager d'accord alors moi est ce
que je peux vous proposer c'est l'avion
voyager en avion
l'avion adacore l'avion l'avion je
réfléchis
non non l'avion non d'accord donc pas
l'avion je vous propose peut-être le
train le train le tram a le train je
réfléchis
non le train non plus d'accord bon alors
on sinon on a le car voyager en car à le
quart le quart d'accord le cas
non d'accord donc pas le quart non plus
alors c'est non à la moto voyager en
moto moto la moto il faut monter sur une
moto
non j'ai pas envie d'accord bon alors
une dernière
la montgolfière la montgolfière au
ballon on veut le fier
à la montgolfière ah d'accord oui oui je
veux je veux monter dans une
montgolfière
j'adore j'adore la bourgogne pierre donc
la montgolfière écouté très bien je vous
fait signer le papier juste vous signez
là la montgolfière âge d'or super genre
merci au revoir au revoir à bientôt à
bientôt
bonjour je suis sourde voyager
avions trains
car
moto
montgolfière
au revoir